hi everyone
i'm maurice samuels the director of the
yale
program for the study of anti-semitism
and it's my great pleasure to welcome
you here today
to the next installment in our benjamin
and barbara zucker lecture series
uh before i hand it over to my colleague
caroline dean who will introduce today's
speaker
i just want to say a word about how it's
going to work today
this is a webinar format so the audience
members are not
visible or audible but we do want to
hear from you
so if you have questions and we hope you
do please submit them
at any time including during the talk
itself
using the q and a function at the bottom
of your screen
don't use the chat and don't raise your
hand
we use the q a function only at the
bottom of the screen
and then i will filter those questions
to to professor benkyat um
during the question um section so
uh now without further ado i will turn
it over to
my uh colleague carolyn dean who is the
walter j stiller professor of history
and french at yale university
to present today's speaker thank you
maureen
welcome everyone i'm i'm delighted to
have this opportunity
to introduce uh professor ruth ben giat
ruth ben giat is a historian an educator
and a commentator on fascism
authoritarian leaders and propaganda
and the threats these present to
democracies around the world
professor she is a professor of history
and italian studies
at nyu or new york university she's the
author of seven books
and many essays among them i should say
two extremely important books fascist
modernities
italy 1922 to 1945
and italian fascisms empire cinema
also an important second project
dealing with italian empire and she's
published obviously much more
including in cnn the new yorker the
washington post
now she's here to discuss with us uh
themes from her newest book strong men
from mussolini to the present which just
came out last year with norton
and this this strong man examines the
authoritarian playbook
illiberal leaders have used for a
century
so with that please join me in welcoming
professor ruth ben yat
thank you thank you to everyone for
coming
and to carolyn and to maurice samuels
for
inviting me to speak so strong men
comes out of my efforts at
civic education in a way it's a book
written for the public
and so i want to start by talking about
why i
wrote it and one of the reasons was
a reaction to a rather intense
period of revisionism of history
of by the global right to minimize the
violence of the authoritarian past
we see leaders rehabilitating
autocratic predecessors as putin's
putting up statues of stalin
but russian scholars who write the wrong
things about
stalin's mass graves are are imprisoned
you can't talk about the nazi soviet
pact uh in russia anymore
nor polish collaboration with with the
holocaust in poland
um both sonar and brazil and many others
on the global right falsely claimed that
fascism was a left-wing phenomenon
and this is done of course to tar the
left with fascist violence and leave the
right with clean hands and this is a
very common
talking point around the world
and even when we see like a rally
that the far right proud boys held
in the states in september 2020 i'll
show you a slide later
not only you have the confederate flag
of course but you have
proud boys wearing a t-shirt that says
pinochet did nothing wrong referring to
the
chilean dictator so i really felt that
to understand what's going on today
including those who spread hatred in
america we need a historical
and global perspective on a century of
authoritarianism
and of course bringing this global lens
the historical lens
to uh to bear on america was
crucial to this book project and it was
attempt by me and american
to understand what was happening to to
us under donald trump
and it's the first book it came out in
november um
just after the election a week after the
election it's the first book to place
the trump presidency
in the context of a century of
authoritarian history
and i had written many things predicting
he would follow a kind of authoritarian
playbook referring to 21st century
authoritarianism where you come to
office
via elections and you manipulate
elections to try and stay there
and so it was intended as a kind of
warning
that no country is immune from
the lure of leaders who appear on the
scene and legitimize
existing extremist uh and antidemic
and anti-democratic tendencies and make
uh racism part of their platforms and
legitima is also the idea that violence
is a way to
cause problems to deal with enemies of
the state
and to move history forward and we saw
this coming to a climax in january 6.
so um the book is divided into three
periods uh the fascist period the age of
military coups
and what i call new authoritarianism
which starts with the end of the cold
war
and i chose to focus mainly on
right-wing strong men so i'm just giving
you the context now
in part because of my training in
fascism and i was also interested in
individuals who
damage or destroy democracies rather
than
kind of inherited power as in china or
north korea
but clearly these right as in
personality cults and
tactics of violence the the right and
the left-wing
uh authoritarian things unfold in
dialogue and i make that clear in the
book
and the core of the book are chapters on
what i call the authoritarian playbook
the tools of rule
and propaganda corruption virility the
myth of national greatness and violence
and each one goes over a hundred years
and this was quite challenging to write
it at times i had wished i
i had just done a biographical approach
you know everything on mussolini
everything on hitler
but i wanted the reader to be able to
see for example with propaganda
what changes and what stays the same
over a hundred years
and just to define my terms i use the
term strong strongmen to refer
to leaders who are a subset of
authoritarians
who use all these tools including
masculinity or machismo
as a tool of political legitimacy so the
virility is very important in how they
uh
relate to their own people and also in
their relationships with foreign despots
um whether they actually wreck democracy
or
as happens in the 21st century they're
aspirational and they
they damage it so
it's not a book of comparative politics
where i'm saying trump
is like hitler but a history that traces
through lines
um through a hundred years like the
fascists who
who fled to franco spain and then went
on to pinochet's chile
and then on some of them on to uh
berlusconi's italy
or the influential position of opus dei
catholics in the governments of franco
pinochet
berlusconi and trump and of course
the groups that recur as the strongmen's
victims
nomadic peoples whether the bedouin of
libya or roma people religious
minorities of course
jews and muslims and jehovah's witnesses
who are famously persecuted by hitler
but perhaps less known they're also
persecuted by putin
um so against this
backdrop i wanted to talk about
the myth of national greatness in
particular
the contrast between this idea uh of
that the strongmen will bring
the nation to greatness and the chaos
and destruction that these states have
caused and it's really amazing how
the myth of authoritarianism as
efficient and productive the idea that
the trains run on time
with mussolini it's really endured it's
been hard to
fail this myth and or the idea that
franco and pinochet brought stability to
their countries
and of course anti-semitism recurs in
this tragic history of
wastes of life of through genocides
through loss of human and
financial resources of the state through
killings through
forced exiles you know hundreds of
thousands people going into exile
through capital flight and acts of
plunder
against demonized categories of people
uh
you know plundered bodies plundered bank
accounts and property
so i also want to talk about
personality cults and the idea that the
strong men alone
can bring the nation to greatness and
the projects of national purification
that come with this
and some of these if you look at the big
uh
course of a hundred years of history
some of these are counter revolutionary
projects
uh against leftists so you have from the
fascist to the cold war
leaders like pinochet up through
bolsonaro and
and trump and the rhetoric for example
of william barr
who was attorney general until recently
uh with the police and
the way he talks about enemies and
anarchists jurisdictions
that very much draws on this lineage
and of course also perceived racial and
demographic
emergencies due to the decline of white
births and possible
quote invasions of the country by
non-whites
this is something that recurs with very
similar rhetoric
from the fascists up to orbon in hungary
and in brazil today among the global
right
and of course where demographic concerns
surface
so does anti-semitism so i'm going to
share
my screen now
and just get rid of this
and here's just a slide from the proud
boys rally
because i really think it's important to
keep
this global reach of the far
right as it's manifesting in america and
america and elsewhere with anti-semitism
with racism
and it's too easy for us to forget about
the uh the other side of things and
and but it's all of a whole and i think
we need to see this in more of a global
framework
so um
one of the things that recurs is why do
these
figures hold an appeal at certain times
in history and one
recurrence that uh comes you know over
and over in the book
is that when countries have been through
a period of
a lot of social emancipation could be
gender equity racial equity it could be
workers rights
secularization times when male authority
and male status feel threatened
this is when the idea of the leader as
omnipotent and infallible
compensates for these anxieties he is
the anchor of the nation he is the
embodiment
of the aspiration to national purity
and one dynamic and those of you
familiar
with the fascist years this will be
familiar
it's very important that the strongman
doesn't just embody
he doesn't just represent the nation
like
a democratic leader he embodies the
nation
he takes unto into himself the sorrows
the victimhood of the nation so he
physically embodies it
and this is an interesting um
uh this is by a trump uh trump pro-trump
painter john mcnaughton called respect
the flag
and it's it's about the uh controversy
over nfl
kneeling to protest police uh racism and
brutality
but what i'm what i would like you to
see here
is how trump the way that trump is
depicted he's
cl he's stricken he shows emotions that
indeed the
um uh famously non-empathetic
trump didn't really have but he's
clutching the tattered flag to himself
again he's
full of sorrow and so he represents the
emotions that the nation perhaps
can't express for itself and so all of
these figures
are able to this was of course famously
said of hitler that when he would
give speeches he was expressing things
that people
felt they didn't know how to express
themselves
and this becomes important when uh
minorities are persecuted and the the
leader is
the embodiment of kind of the good
nation
and here's another to do with fantasies
of national purity
so of course they are acclaimed from
below they
are uh there by the will of the people
and this is true whether they're elected
or whether as in qaddafi's case they
come in by military coup
and but they also are getting
inspiration from divine sources
so here is a classic both this is both
these
phenomena are represented in this
billboard it's with you we embrace
glory this is the people telling gaddafi
from below
that he elevates them and yet he's
looking
uh heavenward beca and and qaddafi used
to stop in the middle of his speeches
and as and and look up to the heavens as
though he was getting divine
inspiration so
strongmen national purity uh projects
usually leverage three separate time
frames
one is uh utopia and of course
the desire for a pristine and perfect
national community has justified state
racism anti-semitism
uh all of these kind of you know racial
states
that's obvious but nostalgia is also
very important
for better times and so it's never just
making the nation great
it's making the nation great again so
mussolini had the roman empire
erdogan in turkey today looks back to
the ottoman empire
uh and various other examples the
spanish empire for franco
of course hitler had aryan civilization
and today the global right often makes
reference to christendom
whether it's in brazil or in hungary um
or in italy harking back to the middle
ages to defend the kind of
white european heritage seen as besieged
by migrants
by jews and here we have of course soros
is the you know international symbol of
that could be indigenous peoples or all
all of these peoples at once right so
this is a
a propaganda campaign and repetition's
very important in propaganda
don't let uh sorrows have the last laugh
and so we're going to encounter this
again the jew who
is not only polluting the the purity but
is
also somehow exploiting the nation and
this
is this goes through a hundred years of
authoritarian history
so i want to just talk uh for this
audience you're probably more familiar
with
a nazi anti-semitism so i want to just
talk a little bit about
the the italian fascist version and show
you some
of this propaganda and
years before hitler came to power
mussolini started talking in the 1920s
about a racial emergency he said that
you know cradles were
empty and cemeteries were full and
quote yellow and brown people were at
the doors and there was this kind of
demographic and racial emergency
and you know research on how
the anti-semitic laws happened it didn't
happen until 16 years after
mussolini came to power in 1938
uh was what laws against the jews
preceded by
colonial anti-uh racist laws in 1937
and so it's very important that the
colonial context the
anti-semitic laws come in the middle of
this packet
um that was inspired by when uh
when the fascists went into ethiopia and
and um and this kind of set off a new
phase
of of feeling there was a racial
emergency
and mussolini newer research has shown
that it wasn't just that mussolini was
kind of tolerated jews and used them in
a way that hitler
would never have done margarita sarfati
mussolini's mistress was very very
useful ally to him
in mainstreaming him and getting him
important contacts with american
diplomats very very early on
um but he also was as newer research has
shown
a a fierce anti-semite of long-standing
and this was not um made evident
for until fairly recently and so
in 1936 already he starts musing
publicly
in articles that sometimes he doesn't
sign but he writes them they're
kind of anonymous and at one point this
this always struck me
he said i'll say it in italian first
intro
too much the too much jewishness uh
justifies anti-jewishness so this is the
classic the jews are having too much
influence and so we are
you know legitimated to take measures
against them
and um of course the anti-semitic laws
drew on the nuremberg laws
in germany but again they're part of
this kind of
larger packet of defending racial
prestige
and um and what's interesting is because
fascist italy had plenty of uh church
anti-judaism and you know catholic
traditions of
anti-semitism it did not have the
political anti-semitism and the pogroms
of eastern europe so propaganda became
very very important if we're always
looking
uh with the authoritarian playbook how
propaganda works together with the other
tools so propaganda took on a
highly and elevated importance of a big
intent it was a very intense
campaign over these few years because
there wasn't as much of a tradition
of uh violence and discrimination
against
jews in the way there were was in
eastern europe certainly
and you know this will be familiar to
many of you this is
uh the jew is criminal but you know
effective propaganda will use
will blend together many different
slogans and
tropes and fears so he's also the jew is
also a communist
and these are him being defanged this is
banks this is the stock market so he's
controlling everything and he's being
justly um disciplined
um and his threat is being cut off
there's also of course
it's like castration there's all kinds
of things going on
that's a very economical image and
the national purity is very interesting
for this this is
this was the defense of the race it was
the major
um very very interesting
surreal images in this um
in this periodical and in early
scholarship it was
when there was difficulty in wanting to
accept anti-semitism as part of fascism
it was deemed an extremist publication
later it comes out that it's published
by the ministry of national education
and the people all the editors are
within the university system as
researchers etc
but here we have uh david of course
and with the fingerprint of jewish
criminality so this is a very
good example of the outsider the jew
who's also inside
ruining and polluting this this
christian heritage right so it's a very
stark
image and then we're going to come back
to this
um just another example where
the uh it's the global dimension is
important
so these are kind of blacks of harlem
and here is
a jew who uh the kind of you know very
the trope of they they can seem
civilized but they're actually
uh barbaric so he's got uh the
he's got some things to do with the
tuxedo
and then underneath he's got the brass
the the grass skirt
so um let's see
make sure i have my time so
these kinds of um projects
obviously continued and there's no time
here to
trace out all the post-war anti-semitism
what i want to do is just touch on
berlusconi italy and touch on trump
and when berlusconi he's very very
important in the history of strongmen
and national purity projects he
he lays down a template which which
leaders like trump
um not consciously borrowed from but
he laid down this path um 1994
and then in the uh 2000s he brings the
far right into government
and eventually his party forze italia
fuses
and merges with the far right party so
he legalizes
and legitimates and mainstreams
extremist tendencies
he also uh he he revives these kind of
demographic anxieties and the program
of forza italia was quote catholic faith
nation patria family and order which is
a classic right-wing authoritarian
program
and there was a lot of talk of again
demographic crisis
which is perennial in italy and the
center left
governments of course also worried about
demographic emergency
but in the berlusconi governments it was
wedded to
demonizing migrants detaining migrants
berlusconi was one of the first to have
large-scale detentions of migrants
uh legitimating the the far right
and so you had you know extremists
people who
were really on the fringes with direct
ties back to
you know neo-fascism who now were in
parliament
so all of this process of mainstreaming
is happening and of course the
revisioning of history
so in an interview in 2003 to boris
johnson
now uh prime minister and nicolas farrow
a right-wing historian berlusconi said
mussolini never killed anyone he just
sent people into confinement to have
vacations
referring to these islands like ponza
where actually torture was practiced
so the whole packet of what became um
the far-right uh demographic and
racial um anti-migrant berlusconi kind
of
uh sets this up early on
and so
now we come to trump and i have up here
this is the former representative steve
king who
is a liaison with the european right
and this is a tweet where he quotes
approvingly
the dutch rightist gilders
he understands that culture and
demographics are destiny we can't
restore our civilization with
somebody else's babies and
justifiably there's been huge amount of
tension attention paid to the ties of
the gop
and russia and and
which is another you know place uh
hotbed of uh
right-wing nationalism but i think uh we
still
need to understand the integration
of the gop uh with
the far-right politicians and
representative king was just
a case one case among many in fact
so as many of you will be aware racism
was an
axis of trump's national project
and a space in which you know
confederate uh
fetishism uh mingled with you know
people who never accepted the end of
segregation
uh anti-immigration fears of quote the
browning of america
and this started during the campaign
where he
very uh he he signaled
to far-right uh access when i started
writing about trump
uh when he retweeted neo-nazi memes
about black criminality
starts using swastikas he starts
retweeting images of
monkeys trying to cross the border open
racist images
and here's the famous uh crooked hillary
with the dollar bills and the star that
his people claimed was a sheriff's star
and not a jewish star
so you know very very obvious
attempts at mainstreaming what was
already there
um racism anti-semitism um
anti-democratic tendencies extremism all
of that
so it makes perfect sense and the
strongman world
that the man whose daughter and
son-in-law are observant jews
would also be the one to praise
neo-nazis of charlottesville as
very fine people and he's played a
double game while in office
pursuing orthodox jews successfully
with a pro-israel policy while
increasing distrust of american jews
with comments about their dual loyalties
and their homeland
really being israel and so and of course
the national purification project rears
its head
which played itself out uh with
you know increased hate crimes increased
anti-semitism increased
hate crimes against muslims and
especially anti-immigration policy
and spearheaded by stephen miller a jew
connected to far-right networks for many
many years
and as i argue in strongmen
the intensity of the trump
administration's efforts to do
undue decades of progress and
integration
and democrats somehow you know chain
turn the demographic clock back
really resembles earlier counter
right-wing counter-revolutions and if we
factor in all that happened to the civil
service we haven't even begun to process
the scope of and the fury of what
uh happened within government as well um
so auntie by now and he's he's out of
office but anti-semitic
uh linked tropes and images fled from
many directions
and um we have you know
the q anon is getting a lot of um
attention as a conspiracy theory
and which draws on the same kind of
paranoias
of um jews dominating the world and
you know murdering children it's not
specifically directed at jews
but many of the people espousing it or
also anti-semites also say things about
jews and this kind of paranoid
when this paranoid world view is
increasing so are other forms of
intolerance
so i'm just going to end with the last
uh these last images are very disturbing
from the film that was shown at the
rally on january 6 that preceded the
assault on the capital
and um there's a chain of images that
bring
up the classic idea of a cabal right
so here we have the hollywood sign
that's the very
one of the first images that the rally
goers saw
and here we have chuck schumer
wearing a kente cloth and
this connects back to
the jew who's also somehow degenerate
racially and the background for these
images of hollywood
and schumer here the text is the
narrator is saying
quote for too long a small group
in our nation's capital has reaped the
rewards of government
while the people have borne the costs so
the cabal
again and of course the last the first
and last images of this film are
straight out of authoritarian leader
calls
this is what people saw that stayed on
screen
as the rally dispersed and they started
to go toward the capitol
and i will stop there
thank you um so much that really gives
us
um a lot to discuss here we actually saw
the the same image
jason stanley who spoke to us a couple
weeks ago also
showed the uh image
of schumer in the kente cloth so just
to remind um people uh if you have a
question
and we hope you do please submit it
using the q a function
at the bottom of your screen don't raise
your hand we're not seeing those or
don't write anything in the chat
so we already have a bunch of questions
and i know carolyn and i both have a
bunch of questions too
so i think i'll start um with this
question from the audience
as you describe it your book emphasizes
the continuity between
strong men from mussolini to the present
can you also talk about how they differ
i'm thinking of the frequent mention
today of illiberal democracies
or sophisticated autocrats who rely on
the vocabulary of democracy
without respecting the thing itself
yeah that's a great question and and one
of the
i felt it was really important
to go back and look back over a century
of
authoritarian history to really because
when people are
are the word fascism is back people
are comparing bolsonaro or trump to
fascists and as a historian
i really wanted to go back and look at
give each specific period it's due
look at the through lines but really
respect those differences
in so the whole first part of the book
is how they get to power and
each period so you know fascist era is
one thing
military coups is a totally different
thing so
today um i make it really clear and also
in every chapter that
i call it new authoritarianism and this
is where you come to
power mostly by elections you manipulate
elections to stay
there and information for example with
propaganda
it's really interesting how much stays
the same like the canons of personality
cults
are they really haven't changed but of
course
social media and
it kind of soups up and accelerates
everything to do with propaganda
because propaganda works on saturation
on repetition
on the same message with tiny variations
and this is what social media
does best so there's that tension
between
what is different and what is the same
and another thing is
um the way that there's a chapter on
resistance
and the way that resistance is practiced
is also helped by social media today
so that for example the classic image
from other eras of authoritarianism of
the
police banging down they're banging on
the door of the resistor
and the resistor has to hide his his or
her documents
right in the past we wouldn't see this
we'd hear about it in memoirs or
you know exiles now in putin's russia
for example
it's live streamed by the resistor and
they create these communities of empathy
and one um dissident he he lives
in on twitter he videoed his hard drive
being flown out by a drone he sent his
drone to his friend's house and so
on twitter everybody watched the drone
leave with his hard drive carrying it to
safety
so that's an example of how um things
change
great carolyn i don't know if you want
to jump in uh yeah i actually
do i kind of have a follow-up to that um
uh that question which you answered so
so clearly
uh a a larger framework and a smaller
one really briefly
um you talked about the importance of
efficiency
trains running on time obviously hitler
built the autobahn and this kind of
thing
and and it's see and obviously this
coexists with this new kind of media
presence etc etc that these strong men
have
but it strikes me that that the
signature of
authoritarian leaders at least in the in
in say i'm thinking bolsonaro
or trump or is kind of a that
is chaos and i and anarchy and i kind of
wondered
um how how you make sense of that and
then really briefly the larger framework
again is it you also you pointed out
that this
all really takes off in i presume the
90s at the end of the cold war
with these the so-called triumph of
liberal capitalist democracy
whereas fascism in the 20s and 30s is
clearly
born of the collapse of liberal whatever
version of liberal capitalism um existed
then and i so i wondered if
how that if that's important if how that
just to just to again this is in this
strain of
difference i guess yeah um
i one of the the macro themes of the
book
was to um
bust this myth of authoritarian
efficiency
and i i i wanted to
i throughout the book in each chapter i
focus on the chaos on the
destructiveness
so what we know for example from uh
those
those who study who know the the the
fascist anti-semitism
the plundering of assets how jews had to
give up their assets the city the state
seized their assets right and gave them
you know very little back or nothing at
all
this is this is one phase in
a plundering of business so we hear that
authoritarians great for business
right because it brings stability well
it's it's very good for
certain big business if you're in the
oil industry
or weapons like the the sectors that
strongmen
care about it's good for you like with
trump big pharma
mining but business as a whole
and small business has been decimated
over and over again around the world by
strong men and that's very important and
we don't hear enough about that
so putin for example has jailed
tens of thousands of businessmen because
if your company does too well he goes
after it and it's a phenomenon known as
predation predate you know to be a
predator
so authoritarian states not surprising
are predatory states
and we don't we hear about the violence
of the the predatory violence and what
they do to bodies
locking them up and killing them we
don't hear what they do to capital
we don't hear how they ruin um you know
family businesses that have been there
for for for decades
right for generations and the same is
true in erdogan's turkey
where over 32 billion dollars worth of
assets and schools and businesses have
been seized
by erdogan so this is this is part of it
the other thing just quickly is
their governance structure is highly
chaotic with constant recycling of
people
um even like somebody like pinochet who
seemed like you know the famous picture
of him with the dark glasses he seems
statuesque he seems stable he reshuffled
his government
like over 40 times so because nobody's
loyal enough
because of the same things we've lived
through with trump this is classic
it's like constant it's constant chaos
and
in fact some of them like gaddafi and
idi amin
they really psychologically they thrived
on chaos
and chaos is a psychological weapon in
in
in all these states whether they rock
wreck democracy or not it's constant
scandal constant outrage
uh constant chaos of one form and
another and it's exhausting to people
even if their life's not at risk as in a
true dictatorship it's exhausting and
authoritarianism plays on us being
exhausted from the chaos
so um so interesting and here's a
a question um from the audience and
something that that i think has occurred
to a lot of
us you know trump famously doesn't
read you know he's not a student of
history so
where does he how did he so perfectly
follow all of this authoritarian you
know all these authoritarian models is
it
instinctual for him or or how it how did
he
do this yeah it's so interesting uh
because he really does
follow it i mean i i was able to predict
almost everything he did and and the
gop's response not because i'm psychic
but because i have studied this stuff
and i'm always
upset that i'm right i would love to be
wrong but i haven't been wrong
unfortunately
and this is because number one they have
similar personalities
and so they structure their governance
in the
in similar ways which produces similar
results
so for example all of them have these
inner sanctums
i call them also cocoons with sycophants
and
family members it's very important to
have sons in law i have a whole
paragraph on sons-in-law
from channel of mussolini up to jared
kushner and these are
these it's because they can't have any
proper feedback
so so that's one example also the
impulsiveness the chaos the
vindictiveness
um all of that is the same and so it
leads to
similar outcomes now trump is indeed
he is different than everybody who came
before him because he doesn't read
so so of course there but but none of
them there is no manual
although they do watch what each other
does
so hitler learned from mussolini he
studied him very closely
and they also watch very carefully how
they fall so when qadhafi saw what
happened to
saddam hussein he actually changed his
policies
and cooperated with the west because he
didn't he said i'm not going to end up
being dragged out of a hole which is
actually what happened to him
but then when that happened to him putin
became very obsessed with arab spring
and he watched over and over again
the footage of gaddafi being killed and
he then
had his own crackdown um 2012 he
he started he came back to the
presidency but he really cracked down
and he had mass protests
but this was also because he was worried
the arab spring would spell the end for
him
so it's instinct it's personality
similarities
but it's also there is some monitoring
going on so
so interesting so here's a question from
um
our colleague sam moyne um who says
brilliant
this is brilliant ruth but i'm wondering
how we avoid sweeping with too broad a
brush
and stigmatizing legitimate or even
uplifting political
arguments or worse for example it has to
be legitimate to call out
elites um and i've never seen a more
utopian
moment in this country than when barack
obama was running but i'm left unsure
whether you think such things are too
dangerous given scary talk of cabals or
right-wing utopian discourse
um for the detailed response read the
book
but um calling for good example calling
out elites
so when because they're also different
i don't use the word populism too much i
because um populism is an ideology
uh used by mussolini and it's there are
populist parties
but a lot of the the authoritarians are
not populists like
pinochet was not a populist for example
but calling out elites
can be very solitary can be be very
healthy
except when authoritarians and and
and a lot of these uh populist parties
are doing it today it's a
it's a it's a foe calling out because in
fact one of the biggest hypocrisies
uh that exists is uh the idea of the
anti-globalist
that whole rhetoric of anti-globalist
because who is a bitter who is a bigger
globalist than trump
his whole business model was licensing
his name
all over the world um he and ivanka even
today have chinese trademarks
or or putin and think of the the
post-communist
version of anti-globalism which involves
calling out elites
western elites they all have their money
their illicitly gained money stored in
offshore finance
networks which are mostly in the west
so they these are the biggest globalists
that there are
so so this is why it's very
this is why the tool the kind of toolbox
is important because propaganda or
rhetorical themes such as
anti-elitism they when they're married
with corruption which is what i've been
talking about
with with uh exfiltrating assets
like putin does to globalist havens
um when you when you see it in that
frame and you don't take
eat only one of them when you keep them
in in their
kind of context then that's
there's nothing salutary about that
that's just corruption
and that's the basis of authoritarianism
um so a question from another colleague
from katie trumpner
who would like to hear more about the
historic links between
mussolini and hitlerian fascism and
imperialism
and also whether you see similar
geopolitical aspirations
among strong men today like the revenges
nostalgia for lost empires like greater
hungary
or the ottoman empire things like that
so for the first part of uh italian
fascism and imperialism
um so
you know we we actually don't know
we don't know enough about the global
reach
of italian fascism but what is very
interesting is that the model
of empire that mussolini was
um propagating
it was a little bit different because
mussolini
wanted to do territorial expansion and
he did you know eventually in the
balkans and world war two
but he also wanted to recuperate
for the empire the little italies around
the world
this kind of soft power soft imperialism
that involved the diaspora and in this
as in so many other things
mussolini is links to uh better than
hitler to 21st century
authoritarians such as modi or duterte
who make a big they're not they're not
invading territory because that's less
common today
but they are using the diaspora to have
a sense of a greater nation
in fact the chapter in the book is
called a greater nation
and it deals with these themes of exile
these themes of calling out to the
diaspora
as well as uh you have an erdogan who's
like you know aggressive and and
destabilizing
because of his desire and he says very
clearly we want turkey
we want the you know turkeys should uh
the empire should go
you know he he includes territories that
are now part of greece
right so so that that there's something
there
what's one way for example that trump is
not a fascist at all
is that um he is interested in kind of
plundering the state which they did but
a lot of them today are not interested
in territorial expansion i mean putin is
but sometimes the greater the rhetoric
of the greater
um the greater nation uh it less
less frequently translates into
armed aggression
and for this reason it also plays more
on the diaspora
um so a couple people are really
um you know wondering about um
trump's jewish children that you
referred to
you know and some people you know one
person said how can you know how can
he be called a fascist or a strongman or
anti-semitic if he has jewish children
and grandchildren and
and you know that and then other people
just want to hear more about what you
meant when you said that that actually
um makes him
stronger in a sense to be able to claim
that link so the the issue of him having
a daughter who converted to orthodoxy
because of
jared it means nothing
for the thing strong men are completely
amoral and transactional
so mussolini also he he was a huge
anti-semite and he ended up you know
sending jews to their deaths
and he had a jewish mistress um
when he needed to have one because she
was useful to him
so the and it's the same as you know
uh people who say they're they're not
racist because they had a a black lover
it's this it's it's it's it's a mis
it's a misplacement of the question what
is very
interesting is trump's ability
to as one of the most
profane and unpious individuals was able
to be the one who was acclaimed by
orthodox jews and by evangelical
christians
as ruling with a divine mandate
and this goes back to mussolini who no
one was more anticlerical and atheist
than mussolini and yet he was the one
who solved the church state question and
created vatican city and got
the pope to say he's there by the will
of providence
so this is this transactional they will
be whatever the you need them to be they
will ally with anyone
uh you need they need to ally with
and they and trump has delivered for
orthodox jews
uh with moving the embassy and he has
delivered hugely for evangelical
christians so it's no wonder that
they say that he's been put in office by
the will of god
um so if we look at
a kind of personality who's completely
immoral
and yet is so skilled at um
at connecting with people and has this
particular kind of manipulative charisma
to be embraced as
as a leader of a certain type they are
also the ones who
have these crazy alliances like
berlusconi too he was
hugely misogynist and yet one of his
biggest bases
was housewives so there's always
this question of um how can people
back someone who does this is it it
it unfolds in different arenas um
with this kind of ruler um so i'm
curious how you would respond to
um a question uh that we're getting
about
um illiberal tendencies on the left
so you know so-called cancel culture or
the movement to shut down um you know
uh uh conservative opinion you know
so so-called so do you um do you see
this
what would you say to someone who says
oh the left uh
does this too i mean depends what you
mean by this
um i yes there are many people who write
to me who are
i rate because i don't have chavez or
castro in my book
and they see that as somehow implicitly
i'm saying that only the right does
these things
so um which is
of course i had my reasons for only
deciding
as we all do have our reasons to delimit
our projects in certain ways
but
i mean can't the cancel culture thing is
very interesting
because it's being used most effectively
by the right
and i have a picture in my book uh from
the 1920s it's a nazi
party propaganda poster of hitler
being cancelled of hitler with tape
a taped mouth because uh in the 20s
after he got out of jail for his push he
there was a ban
on him speaking in public for you know
because of his hate speech
and so the nazis responded by making him
into
a canceled hero and so
there were many posters they put out
with his mouth taped and one of them
says
of all the people i you know i'm the one
who's
who's forbidden to speak um and this was
highly effective
at at making hitler into a maverick and
a truth-teller
who was silenced by the establishment so
what i could say about the liberal
tenses
of the left is that in times of
polarization
you do see similar tendencies uh
of of people fearing that they're being
cancelled and it's a symptom of also
a kind of avoiding and dearth
of a center right and
so that's that's a huge problem and in
the states right now there's
there's you know the polarization is
really uh
accelerating um and and that's that's
very very bad
that's as we know okay so maybe one more
question from the audience and then i'll
give carolyn the last
question so um so first one more
uh question from the audience which is
you know we talked about how
uh trump doesn't read and that it's sort
of instinctual or part of his
personality that he's picking up on
these things
but do you also draw a distinction or
could you say a little bit more
between those elements like people and
i'm thinking here people like bannon or
stephen miller who probably are
reading uh and are you know explicitly
learning this is william quack's
question here
um about um you know are there some who
are
actually um studying the fascist
playbook
explicitly yeah another reason i don't
call trump of fascists
is uh actually fascism isn't
enough to capture the scope of the
knowledge and wisdom of um
around trump meaning trump has been
surrounded by people like roger stone
who has decades of experience and wisdom
about how to take down democracies and
roger stone and paul manafort
worked for mobutu in the congo and who's
in my book
they worked for ferdinand marcos they
were hired i have their foreign agent
registration act
paper they were hired by marcos in the
80s
to kind of oversee his fraudulent
election
so roger stone is one example there are
people around trump who have a wealth of
of authoritarian history and knowledge
that is way bigger than fascism
um so it's actually more scary if
anything could be scarier than fascism
the same with bannon i mean bannon is
a fan of all things fascists but he is
you know he even moved to europe i mean
he is
firmly immersed in the global right in a
way that transcends
fast historic fascism so so when we talk
about
there's many reasons not to call trump a
fascist although trump
and and co uh trump and colleagues
obviously take things from the fascist
era
absolutely right and so in fact as jason
stanley's book shows there are
continuities in these things so
that's why many people say well trump is
what fascism looks like now
i prefer to use the word authoritarian
because
he may not be reading but the people
around him
are steeped in knowledge of
anti-democratic action
of theory of psychological warfare
that's very important
for roger stone and many people around
trump
including people who stormed the capital
some of the
military who stormed the capital they
were trained in psyops
psychological warfare and bannon in fact
uh
miller and bannon what when they when
they came into power and they did the
the ban on um travel from muslim
countries
this was a classic authoritarian shock
event
so in my book i talk about shock events
authoritarians love
shock events and they create windows of
chaos
this is with the question about chaos
this was
this was preparing this was a
psychological warfare as well as a
bureaucratic
warfare um it was telling people that
chaos
will be a feature and not a bug of the
trump presidency
um and that government will be used
against you
and and so this is this is why
um it's much bigger than fascism
remnants of fascism scarily so
great um carolyn if you want to ask the
last uh
question here oh you're you're muted
carol
sorry there we go there we go i just had
just two i guess
wrap up questions looking toward the
future um
given that i'm sure where a lot of us
are thinking about some of these issues
and one of the things you've talked
about so effectively is how
cancel culture is a common feature of
say
regimes in the 30s and now um except
that now we have social media
and i i and and so and i was thinking
about
marjorie taylor greene or someone like
that who goes on the floor of congress
has tons of a huge audience but then
but has censored across her mask and
that creates the reality
and i wonder can you talk about um
how if it's a peculiarly american
phenomena
or how this the stones and the man and
trump himself have all
created an illusion that it is the
left that is imposing upon our liberties
i'm just it's just a is that american is
that a
fascist theme and is that is that
sort of important do you think to
thinking about
um the kind of new authoritarianism in
the united states since uh you know
american exceptionalism
may have been uh it may be shattered by
by trump's presidency
nonetheless there is still this uh a
commitment to liberty or the use at
least the deployment of liberty as a
really important
theme and i just wondered if you could
talk about
as a way i just are just thinking about
where what we should we should think
about what we should be looking for
going forward
that's just one thing i've just been
really struck by in this whole thing
yeah not only is not american particular
to america
it's the oldest and mussolini when he
was theorizing fascism one of the main
things was that
that form of liberty was tyranny and
there are things that he said about
why democracy is actually a tyranny that
are almost
100 percent echoed by orban in hungary
that liberal democracy becomes a tyranny
um they don't always flesh out the truth
the truly fascistic endpoint today
in their speeches out loud they don't
always say the ending out loud
today um and and orban has his own
catchphrases right about uh electoral
autocracies and and this kind of
keeping the electoral in or the
democracy part in
allows them to have it's a scandal why
does orban have eu funding
this should not be he's ruling by decree
now
but there's there's always been this but
so this whole heritage of political
theory
that goes from the idea of liberty as
tyranny
um and um that we're being censored and
we're being cancelled in our personhood
it goes back to the interwar period the
feeling that
mass society in both the communist
and the american capitalist materialist
vision was extinguishing personhood it
was extinguishing spirituality
and so fascism became this kind of third
way
this was a very popular slogan
that the fascists came up with they
would be the they would preserve
individuality they would preserve
freedom but within a structure
um unlike the anarchy of liberal
democracy and the massification that can
become a tyranny
so it's a it's a history of of rights
being curbed it's it's many people in
your audience
you know written about this but there's
there's nothing
um there's nothing particularly american
about it
the only thing that is um
the thing that is more enhanced and
uh emphasized in america is the
particular
um weight given to individualism
and guns gun ownership as a symbol of
that because american is sex
exceptionalism is not democracy it's
it's
it's gun ownership to the point where
people have
arsenals that are only seen in peace
they're never seen in peace time
in putin doesn't have let people have
private citizens have huge arsenals
so that is something uh and i find it
very telling that
there's been relative silence of all
that's been written about january 6th
and extremism there haven't been that
many
uh articles about guns because the
extremist is nothing without the guns
without
his arsenal or her arsenal so
so the liberty so so if you try and
tease out
what is particularly american about the
this discourses that are happening uh
under have been legitimized by the gop
and they will go
forward trump's not in office anymore
but they are
um it it's very scary that it dates back
to a whole history of illiberalism
okay well on that note we're actually
over and i feel like we could go on all
night but i encourage everybody to buy
your book and um can learn just so much
from it and to really
um thank you for this wonderful talk uh
today and for patiently ask answering
all of our questions
i encourage everyone in the audience to
sign up for the
uh yipsa mailing list so you can find
out about future talks
and please join me in silently alas
thanking professor ben giat so
thank you thank you thanks for the great
questions everyone